just want to keep you abreast of a
developing situation in the east of
Germany this is in the city of Dresden
it's a far east of the country uh quite
near the border with the Czech Republic
where German police say a hostage
situation is underway reports of shots
being fired
um
earlier this morning police are urging
people to avoid
the city center and I've also ordered
dresden's Christmas Market to remain
closed the radio station there was
reporting that shots had been fired at a
building near the main train station
the Tabloid newspaper built has reported
that a woman has been killed but it's
important to say police have not
confirmed that either way but regardless
they have confirmed that a hostage
situation is underway what we understand
to be a shopping center in Dresden there
will be keeping a close eye on what is
happening and will bring you any
developments as and when we get them of
course it'll be a very very busy time of
year around that Christmas Market
shopping area in the city of Dresden
today on Saturday in the run-up to
Christmas